The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: What we
have to do today
is study a very important
example of a two- state system.
That will be the
ammonia molecule,
and will lead us to
understand how masers work.
Masers are what for
microwaves, the same thing
as lasers are for light-- it's
just a different frequency.
Masers is microwaves
and lasers is for light.
It's the same thing.
So it's a very nice application
of two-state systems.
And then we'll discuss over
the last part of the lecture
some aspects of nuclear
magnetic resonance.
I don't think I'll
get to the end of it,
because it's quite
a bit of material.
But we'll try to
see what we can do.
So let me remind you
of the last thing
we were doing last
time, that this
is going to be in the
backdrop of what we do today.
We spoke about Hamiltonians
for a two-state system that
were the most general two by
two Hermitian matrix specified
by four real numbers-- g0
and the three components
of the vector g multiplied
by the Pauli matrices.
This is Hermitian.
This can be written in this
way, in which we've identified
Hamiltonians for spins, in
the sense that g dot sigma--
really, sigma is
proportional to S,
so this is equal to
omega dot S, where
omega-- Larmor--
is 2g over h bar.
And we explained last time
that if you have a term omega l
dot S, spins will rotate
with angular velocity omega l
vector, which means they
rotate around the axis defined
by the vector omega l,
with an angular velocity
equal to the magnitude
of the vector omega l.
So that's Larmor precession.
This Larmor precession in
the case of a magnetic field
is given by minus lambda times
the magnetic field, gamma times
the magnetic field, where gamma
is that constant that relates
the magnetic moment
of the particle
to the spin angular
momentum of the particle.
Then we got, moreover,
that the energy
levels of this Hamiltonian--
this is a two-state systems,
so it's a two-dimensional
vector space
that can be at most
two energy eigenstates.
That's the simple thing
about two-state systems.
These two energy
eigenstates have
the energies equal
to g0 plus/minus g.
And the plus corresponds
to the spin state n plus,
and the minus corresponds
to the spin state n minus.
And you don't have to
talk spin states when
you write this spin
states over here.
The plus, you should think of
spinning in the plus direction,
but the thing that we call
plus is the first basis vector.
And the thing that we call
minus is the second basis vector
of this state space.
Therefore, if you've
given a matrix,
Hamiltonian has nothing
to do with spins.
You still have the notion
that the first basis
vector, whatever it is-- an
iron moving in this direction--
is the mathematical
analog of a spin up.
And the second basis vector--
whatever else it may be--
is the analog of the spin down.
So this will be important
for what we do now,
as we begin the study
of the ammonia molecule,
and its states.
So having reviewed the key
ideas from the last part
of last lecture, are
there any questions?
So let me begin with this
ammonia molecule-- double M,
M-O-N-I-A, is NH3.
It's used as a fertilizer.
It's a gas, has strong
odor, no color, fertilizers,
cleaning products,
pharmaceuticals,
all kinds of things.
It has the shape of a flattened
tetrahedron with a nitrogen
atom at one corner, say, and the
base the three hydrogen atoms.
If it would not be a flattened
tetrahedron, this angle
over here-- if it would
be an equilateral, regular
tetrahedron, this
angle over there
would be 60 degrees,
because this every phase
would be an
equilateral triangle.
But if it's a
flattened tetrahedron,
if it will be totally flat--
then n would be at the base.
The angle in between
these two edges
would be 120 degrees, because
they have to add up to 360.
Well, this has 108 degrees,
so it's pretty flat,
this tetrahedron.
And you can imagine, actually,
this is a two-state system,
because just as the
nitrogen can be like this--
can be up with respect to
the base of the hydrogens,
it could also be down.
And so you can imagine
this molecule rotating,
and suddenly the up
nitrogen goes down,
and this keeps rotating--
a possible transition
of the system, in
which, well, I don't
know if I'm drawing it well.
I don't think so.
But roughly, it could be like
this-- the nitrogen is down.
And this, in principle,
would be like two
possible configurations
of this system.
There's a barrier.
This is in equilibrium,
so if you try to push it,
it's not easy.
But if you did
manage to push it,
it would be stable in
the other direction.
It is as if you had a potential
for the nitrogen-- a V of z--
the direction is z-- in which
it can be here, up or down.
And it's stable in
either one, but there's
a big barrier in between.
So that's the story
of this nitrogen atom.
And we're going
to try to describe
this as a two-state system.
So I need some notation.
Well, I'm going to
have the first basis
state to be called up for N
up, and the second basis state
is going to be called
down for nitrogen down.
And now, I'm going
to try to write
the Hamiltonian for this system.
Well, you know what
sort of happens here.
Your intuition in quantum
mechanics with wave functions
should be similar.
Look-- this is not
the two-state system,
because there may be
many energy eigenstates,
but you know that the ground
state looks like a wave
function, just like this.
And the first
excited state could
look like a wave function
that is like-- oops-- this.
Pretty much the same
thing, but you flip one,
and if the barrier
is sufficiently high,
these two energy levels
are not that different.
So the question is,
how do we model this?
There may be an energy
E0 for the system,
a ground state energy maybe,
and a little bit of a higher
energy.
So we're going to
write the Hamiltonian.
And I'm going to put
E0 for the moment.
And my first basis
state is 1 and up.
This would be the
1 0, and here would
be the 0 1, the
second basis state.
And this is saying
that 1 0, the N up,
is an energy eigenstate
of energy E0.
And down is an energy eigenstate
of energy in up as well.
But that can't be the story.
There cannot be two
degenerate energy eigenstates.
Your intuition tells you
that this is impossible.
One dimensional potential
wouldn't say that.
So there must be
something else happening.
This cannot be the whole
Hamiltonian that describes
the physics of the problem.
So what we're going
to do is try to tinker
with this Hamiltonian,
a simple tinkering that
is going to give us the
physics that we expect.
So I'm going to put a
constant delta here.
This should be Hermitian, so I
should put the delta as well,
another constant there.
For convenience,
however, I'd rather
put the minus sign there.
I will define delta to be
positive for definiteness,
and for convenience, however,
I will put here minus delta.
Now, you could say look,
you say that, but maybe
it's not for convenience.
Maybe it changes the physics.
Well, it cannot
change the physics,
because these things
are the matrix elements
of the Hamiltonian-- the 1 2,
and the 2 1 matrix elements.
And I could decide to change
what they call the first basis
vector, to call it minus
the first basis vector.
This would change the sign of
this, change the sign of that,
without changing those signs.
So this sign is a
matter of a basis.
So we certainly have
not made any assumption
by putting that to be a
minus sign over there.
Now, once you have
this Hamiltonian,
this delta is going
to be some energy.
And that's going to be what
mimics the physics here,
because these states are not
going to be any more energy
eigenstates.
The matrix is not
diagonal anymore.
So the 1 0 vector,
and the 0 1 vector
are not any more
energy eigenstates.
Moreover, it's
interesting to try
to figure out what it has to
do with our previous system.
So this is E0 times 1
minus delta times sigma 1.
And that's a good thing to know.
So in this case,
comparing to this g
is the vector in
the x direction,
because its g
multiplying by sigma 1.
And it has magnitude delta.
So we notice-- and we're going
to make a picture later--
is that g, in this case so
far, is equal to delta times
the unit vector in
the x direction,
minus delta times the unit
vector in the x direction.
So g is equal to delta.
So, OK, we've written those.
Let's then figure out
what are the ground
states and the excited states.
And this is a two by two matrix,
and a simple one, at that.
So you could just
do it, or better
to figure out what we're doing.
We'll use our formulas before.
Yes, George.
AUDIENCE: So why is
it that we mandate
that delta has to be real?
I mean, that's not
the most general form.
PROFESSOR: That's right, it's
not the most general form.
So at this moment,
we're trying to do
what any reasonable
physicist does.
Without delta, it doesn't
match the physics.
So let's try the simplest
thing that can work,
and a delta real--
we'll see if it works.
And if it works, we'll worry
later about different things.
So we'll put the simplest
thing at this moment,
but indeed, we could put
more complicated things.
So given this, in fact, we know
what it the energy eigenstates
should be, or we
more or less can
guess what the energy
eigenstates should be.
Let me tell you the energies
are g0 plus/minus g,
so you're going to get E0
plus delta and e0 minus
delta as the energies--
E excited, and E ground.
And the gap between
these two energies--
the gap between these two
energy levels is 2 delta.
So there we go.
We've already produced
something good.
We have two energy eigenstates.
There should be a small
energy difference,
and that gap is 2 delta.
Now, what are those states?
Well, it's not too hard to
see that the eigenstate that
has this energy is
the excited state, is
1 over square root
of 2, 1 minus 1.
If you add with
this matrix on this,
that's the energy eigenstate.
And the energy
eigenstate for this one
is 1 over square root of 2, 1 1.
Let's write them.
These are the eigenvectors.
Let's write them as 1
over square root of 2,
nitrogen up minus nitrogen down,
and 1 over square root of 2
nitrogen up plus nitrogen down.
So I want to, even though it's
not complicated to do this,
and we have called these states
that way, so it's all clear.
I want you to see how that comes
from our spin way of thinking.
So you know there's
this molecule,
and for this molecule,
only one direction matters.
We could have called
it x, if we wanted.
In fact, maybe x would
have been a better name.
On the other hand,
for spin states,
there are three
dimensions-- x, y, and z.
So we have to think
in an abstract way.
So where is this vector G?
We said G is minus delta Ex.
So this is the x-axis.
This is the y-axis.
This is the z-axis.
G is here.
The vector G goes
back over here,
is minus delta x hat vector.
Now, what if you
have g in that way?
You know that the
excited state is
one of these states over here.
Let's see-- this N plus
is the excited state,
and N minus is the lower state.
So the excited
state should point
in the direction of g
vector, because N corresponds
to the direction
of the g vector.
G is positive here, this
little g is positive.
So g is in there.
N is in there as well,
because g and n are parallel.
And the excited state
should correspond
to N, a vector in
the plus n direction.
So the excited state
should be here.
It's a spin state
in that direction.
That's what that formula says.
And the ground state should
be a spin state in the minus N
direction, so this must
be the ground state.
So this I call
the excited state,
and this the ground state.
And indeed, remember now that
what is your translation.
1 and 2-- the 1 and 2 states
are like the plus and minus
of spins.
So in terms of spin
language, this excited state
is the plus minus the minus.
And this is the plus plus the
minus, because the up is plus,
the down is minus.
So indeed, this state--
you probably remember it.
This is a spin along
the x direction.
So the ground state must be like
a spin along the x direction.
That's here.
The excited state is a spin, the
orthogonal one in the minus x
direction, so it must be a
state orthogonal to this one,
as to this, and it points
in the other direction.
So those are our spins.
And we had that the gap
delta-- the gap is 2 omega.
It's an energy, so
it's what we called
h omega naught a photon--
the transition energy.
I could give this energy in eVs,
but I actually don't have it.
I have the wavelength of the
frequency of the associated
photon.
So this corresponds
to a frequency
nu of 23.87 gigahertz,
and a lambda of about
1.26 centimeters-- more
or less half an inch.
So that is the
transition difference
between these two levels.
So this is something
people knew--
there's two levels
above this molecule,
and they correspond
to the result
of this perturbation
that splits them.
So in a sense, we've got a nice
model-- perfectly reasonable
model, without introducing
much complexity-- of what
this thing is doing.
So let's do a little exercise.
Let's see how does the N
up state evolve in time?
So we have psi at time
equals 0 be in the state up.
What is it later?
There are many ways to do
it-- many, many ways to do it.
The quickest, in principle,
is to think about spins,
even if just a little painful.
But let's think about spins.
Omega l is going to be
around the direction of g.
So think of the
state of the spin.
The N up state, the
up state, is here.
And then it's going to
precess with angular frequency
vector in the direction of g.
So it's going to precess
in the direction of g.
So you can imagine now
this vector precessing.
And it's going to go-- since
it's essentially the minus x
direction-- precession in
time is going to flip it
to the y-axis, and then make
it rotate in the z-y axis.
That's all what
it's going to do.
So you have a picture of
what it's going to do.
We might as well calculate a
little, although the picture is
complete, and the frequency
is known, and everything.
But what you do
here, of course, is
you try to write it in
terms of energy eigenstates.
And the up state is
the 1 over square root
times the sum of e plus g.
And you know the energies
of those two states,
so you know how
they evolve in time.
It will be in the notes.
You can do this.
After you now evolve, with e
to the minus i ht over h bar,
you then go back from
e to g, to up and down,
because that's sort of the
intuition that we want to
Have.
So it's not difficult.
None of these steps
are difficult.
e and g are written in
terms of up and down.
So what does one get?
One gets psi of t is equal e
to the minus i, et over h bar
times cosine of t
delta over h bar,
times the state up plus i
sine of t delta over h bar,
state down.
This is the time evolution, so
the probabilities, for example,
to be up is the square of
this one-- cosine squared
of t delta over h bar.
And the probability
to be down is sine
squared of the same thing.
So this poor nitrogen
molecule, if it
happens to have
the nitrogen up, is
going to start
rotating like crazy,
even if you don't do anything.
It's just sitting there, and
it's rotating up and down,
with a speed doing this thing
23 billion times a second.
Molecule's up and
down, because it's not
in a stationary eigenstate.
Now, here, actually,
you may think
that something is a little
funny, because you would say,
well, the frequency of rotation
is like delta over h bar,
but the Larmor frequency is
supposed to be 2g over h bar,
so it would correspond to a
Larmor frequency of 2 delta
over h bar, which is exactly
the frequency of the photons.
But there's no
contradiction here.
This is, in fact,
rotating at that speed,
at twice that speed.
Because if you remember,
for a spin state,
this was the cosine
of theta over 2.
Therefore, as it changes,
that's the way theta over 2
is changing.
But theta, which is the angle
of this physical rotation,
changes twice as fast.
So it's, again, those
1/2s of spin states that
are very confusing sometimes.
But there's no contradiction.
The sort of Larmor frequency
of the equivalent spin problem
is exactly the same
as the frequency
of the original problem.
So now we want to make this
into something more practical.
And for that, what we
explore is the fact
that this molecule has an
electric dipole moment.
So the molecule as
we pictured it there,
as it happens, the
electrons of the hydrogen
sort of cluster
near the nitrogen.
So this up region
is kind of negative.
The bottom region
is kind of positive,
and there is an electric
dipole moment pointing down.
So this is a pretty
important property
of this molecule,
this dipole moment.
And electric dipoles
we usually call p.
But for some reason-- maybe
I should change the notes,
at some stage or maybe this
is discussed very nicely
in Feynman's
lectures on physics.
He uses mu for this,
like for magnetic dipole.
So I will actually
use mu as well, now.
So this thing has
an electric dipole,
and therefore the energy
is the electric dipole
dotted with the electric field.
And that electric field is
an external electric field.
You have this little dipole,
which is this molecule,
and you put it inside
an electric field,
and there's a contribution
to the energy,
just because the dipole is
sitting on an electric field.
And that means our
Hamiltonian is now changed.
So I will consider
the case in which we
have an electric field
in the z direction--
a positive electric field
so that E is equal to E times z.
And mu would be equal
to minus mu times z,
because it points down.
We've assumed that
the dipole is down.
And the dipole is down
for the case of spin
in the z direction.
So look what we get here--
this energy contribution is
essentially mu E. And
it's the energy that
is acquired by the state in
which the nitrogen is up.
This is for nitrogen up.
So what we've
discovered-- if we want
to model this in the
Hamiltonian is that we can take
the Hamiltonian that we
have-- E0 minus delta,
e0 minus delta, and the energy
of the state up with nitrogen
up, is this one--
mu E. So we add
mu E. And the one
with the spin down
will be the opposite, so
it will be minus mu E.
And this is our reasonable
expectation for the Hamiltonian
of this molecule inside
an electric field.
So this is the NH3 in E field.
So again, we can wonder what
kind of thing happens here.
And the best thing is to
first say this is E0 1
minus delta sigma 1.
And then you see, oh,
it's mu E sigma 3.
So getting to
that, and I realize
this is a little more
painful than the other one.
And we don't have to
do it, because we've
solved the general problem.
And the energies,
this time, are going
to be E of the excited one,
and E of the lower one-- ground
state.
It's going to be E0 plus g.
And g was the magnitude
of the vector g.
So it's the magnitude
of the vector g
that now has components
minus delta 0 and mu E.
So here we get plus
square root of delta
squared plus mu E squared.
And here is 0 minus square
root of delta squared plus mu
E squared.
So there we go.
If we know how the
energies behave,
even if we have some
electric field--
and typically delta
is such, and mu
is such that, for
most electric fields
that you ever have
in the lab-- this
is very small compared to that.
The dipole moment is
sufficiently small
that the energies
that you get from here
are pale compared to the
difference of energies
over there.
So you can approximate.
This is E0 plus delta plus
1/2 mu E squared over delta.
This is for mu E small.
Here E0 minus delta minus
1/2 mu E over delta squared.
And this is when mu E is
much smaller than delta.
Now, the only reason
I point this out
is because it does provide
a technological opportunity
to separate a beam of
particles into excited-
and the ground-state level.
Sort of like
Stern-Gerlach experiment,
you put, now, this beam that
has this ammonia molecules.
And you put them inside
an electric field
that has a gradient.
In a gradient,
this state is going
to try to go to
minimize its energy.
So it's going to go to the
regions of the electric field
where the electric
field is small.
This particle
minimizes its energy
when it goes to the regions
of the electric field
when the electric field is big.
So it's like putting it in
a Stern-Gerlach experiment.
You have your beam,
and you separate them.
You have your beam
and you manage
to separate the things that
can be in an excited state,
and the things that are
in the ground state.
And now what you do is
insert these excited states
into a resonant cavity.
Have a little hole here,
and a little hole here,
and E comes in, and
something comes out.
So we're getting now to
the design of the maser.
The idea that we're
trying to do is
that we try to
make a cavity tuned
to 23.7 gigahertz-- the
frequency associated
with a gap.
And we just insert those Es
over there, these excited states
over there, and hope that
by the time they go out,
they become a g.
Because if they go from E--
say there was an electric field
here to separate them,
and then E's over here.
This is the excited state.
There's no more electric
fields over here.
It just comes into the
cavity as an excited state.
The excited state has
energy E0 plus delta.
And then, if it manages to go
out of the cavity as the ground
state, then it would have
energy E0 minus delta.
It must've lost energy to delta.
That can go nicely into
the electromagnetic field
and become one photon--
a one photon state
in the cavity of
the right frequency,
because the cavity
is tuned to that.
The only difficulty
with this assumption
is that E is an
energy eigenstate.
So energy eigenstates are lazy.
They're stationary states.
They don't like to change.
So there's no reason why
it should go out as g.
It's excited state.
It's perfectly happy to
remain excited forever.
So what must happen
somehow is that there's
an electric field
here in the cavity,
and that stimulates this
thing to make the transition,
because once there's
an electric field,
E is not anymore an
energy eigenstate.
The E of the original
system is not anymore
an energy eigenstate,
and nor is this.
So then it's going
to change in time.
So the problem is a
delicate one in which
we want to somehow have
an electric field here
that is self-consistent
with the idea
that this excited state goes
out as the ground state.
And that's why it's
microwave amplification
by stimulated
emission of radiation,
because you're going to
amplify a signal here.
It's a microwave, 1
centimeter wavelength--
that's a microwave.
And the stimulation is the
fact that this wouldn't do it
unless there's some
electric field already.
So you could say, well, so
how does it get started?
There's no electric
field to begin with.
Well, you know
quantum mechanics,
and you know that in general,
there are little fluctuations,
and there's energies--
small photons, one
or two photons that suddenly
appear because of anything.
Any motion of charges
in here produces
an electromagnetic wave.
So at the beginning, yes--
there's no many photons here.
But somehow, by having it
resonate at that frequency,
it's very easy to
get those photons.
And a few appear, and a few
molecules start to turn in,
and then very soon this is full
with energy, in which there's
a consistent configuration of
some electric field oscillating
and producing precisely
the right transitions here.
So I want to use the next 50
minutes to describe that math.
How do we do this?
Because it just
shows really the sort
of hard part of the problem.
How do you get
consistently a field,
and the radiation going on?
So maybe I should call
this E prime and g prime.
They shouldn't be confused.
E and g are these states
that we had before.
And E prime and g prime, we
never wrote those states,
but they are deformed states
due to an electric field.
OK, so what do we have to do?
Well here is E and g.
And we had a Hamiltonian.
There's going to be an
electric field here,
so this Hamiltonian
is the relevant one.
The only problem
with this Hamiltonian
is that this is going to be a
time-dependent field, something
that we're a little scared
of-- Hamiltonians with time
dependence-- for good
reason, because they're hard.
But anyway, let's try to see.
Today's all about Hamiltonians
with time dependence.
So there's going to
be a time-dependent
is going to be the wave here.
So that's the
relevant Hamiltonian.
But it's the Hamiltonian in the
1 2 basis, in that up nitrogen,
down nitrogen basis.
I want that Hamiltonian
in the Eg basis.
It's better.
It's more useful.
So let's try to see how that
looks-- Hamiltonian in the Eg
basis.
H prime in E equal 1 g equal
2 primes, maybe put basis.
So here is the
Hamiltonian in this basis.
In the 1 2 basis, I have to
pass to the other basis, the Eg
basis.
So it's not complicated.
It takes a little work, but
it's nothing all that difficult.
For example, in the 1 prime h
1 prime, which would be the 1 1
element of this
matrix, I'm supposed
to put here 1 prime is EhE.
And now I'm supposed to
say, OK, what is this?
Well, E is 1 over
square root of 2.
E was 1 over square
root of 2, 1 minus 1.
H is the original H, so it's
E0 plus mu E minus delta minus
delta E0 minus mu E. And E
is 1 1, 1 minus 1, again.
And there's also the
square root of 2.
So at the end, this is a 1/2.
So this is the kind
of thing you have
to do to pass to this basis.
So I think I'll do
that in the notes.
And this calculation is simple.
In this case, it
gives E0 plus delta.
And in retrospect, that sort
of is pretty reasonable.
This is E0 plus delta, and
this is E0 minus delta.
And if you didn't have
an electric field--
indeed in this basis,
the first state
is the excited state
who has this energy.
The second state is the ground
state, and has this energy.
And that makes sense
if there's no mu E.
Well, the mu E still shows
up, and it shows up here.
So that is the
Hamiltonian in this basis,
and the general
state in this basis
is the amplitude to be
excited, and the amplitude
to be in the ground state.
This is the general psi of t.
So your Schrodinger equation in
this mu basis-- not mu basis,
in the Eg basis, you see it's--
Eg basis is the basis of energy
eigenstates if you don't
have electric field.
But once you have
an electric field,
it's not anymore energy
eigenstates, and much worse
if you have a time-dependent
electric field.
So the Schrodinger equation
is i h bar d dt of CE Cg
is equal to this mu matrix.
And now, E0 is totally
irrelevant for everything.
It's a constant of
the unit matrix.
Let's put E0 to 0.
There's no need to keep it.
E0 equal zero.
So we have delta mu E
minus delta times CECg.
I d dt of psi, h psi--
the Schrodinger equation.
Now, the real
difficulty that we have
is that E is a function of time.
So this is not all that trivial.
So what you do to solve this is
simplify the equation by saying
what would the
solution be if you
didn't have a function of time?
Then you would have-- if you
didn't have E, CE Cg of time
would be E to the minus i ht.
So this would be i delta
t-- the energy of this,
if there's no electric
field, the Hamiltonian
will be delta minus delta.
So here, I have my
psi ht over h bar.
And for the lower
state, you would have E
to the plus i delta t
over h bar as solutions,
if you didn't have this.
This would be the solutions.
But we want now better.
So what we're going
to say is well,
that's a solution
if I neglect this.
So this cannot be
the real solution.
So I'll put here beta sub E
of t, and a beta sub g of t.
And sure-- if no electric
field, betas are 1.
They're not necessary.
But if there is
an electric field,
the betas are going
to be complicated,
so we need them there.
So this is like an [INAUDIBLE].
Now you could plug this back,
and calculate what you get.
And it should not
be too surprising
that you're going to get in here
something in which these deltas
are going to disappear, because
this thing takes care of that.
So there's a little
bit of algebra
here, maybe two, three
lines of algebra.
And let me give
you what you get--
I h bar d dt of beta E beta g.
Now the equation is really
for this quantities--
and it's 0 E to the
i omega 0t times mu
E, E to the minus
i omega 0t times
mu E0, beta E, beta g,
where omega 0 is the Larmor
frequency, or 2
delta over h bar.
So some calculation
involved, but I
hope you don't lose track
of the physics here.
The physics is
that the amplitude
to be in E and the
amplitudes to be in g
have now been replaced by beta
and beta g, which are expected
to be simpler
things to calculate.
And in fact, since the
probability to be in E
is the norm of to
this thing squared,
beta is as good as C to know
how likely is the particle
to be in E, or how
likely is the particle
to be in the ground state.
You could use beta, because
they differ by a phase.
So betas have still the
physical significance
of the amplitude
to be in E or g.
And we're still having
an electric field
that is time dependent here.
So it's time to put
the time dependence,
and what are we going to do?
Well we're going to find a sort
of self-consistent operation
of this device, in which we will
have an electromagnetic field,
E. E of t will be
2 E-- letter E,
that now is going to be a
constant with an E0, cosine
omega 0 t-- again the Larmor
frequency or the photon
frequency that is emitted
by the possible transition.
So we will consider the case
when the cavity has already
that electric field
that is going precisely
at the right speed
to do things well.
So this Et, with the 2
conveniently put here,
is equal to E0 E to the i omega
naught t plus e to the minus i
omega naught t.
So when you multiply these
things, what do you get?
Let me do one of
them for you to see.
You get this i--
the top one-- h I'm
going to put to the other side.
Beta E is going
to be beta E dot,
is going to couple
with this to beta g.
So that thing is going to be
this electric field times mu,
so mu e0, the h bar
from the left-hand side,
and you have E to the i omega
naught t multiplying this,
so it's 1 plus E to the 2i
omega naught t times beta g.
So that's the first equation.
Not all that easy, for sure.
Second equation--
i beta g dot is
equal to mu E0
over h bar, 1 plus
e to the minus 2i omega
naught t beta E of t.
And now you have to think
maybe a little like engineers,
or physicists, or
mathematicians--
whatever you prefer.
But you want to
convince yourself
that what you want
to do is true.
And what do you want to do?
I like to forget about
these curves, basically.
That's what we want to do.
Why would that be true?
Well, here's a
reason why it's true.
This is a number that sort of
goes between 1 and minus 1,
with some phase.
Mu E0, however, over h bar,
is a very small number.
Mu E0 we're thinking of--
we're saying compared
to the natural scales of the
problem, this energy, mu E0,
is much smaller than delta.
And delta is the thing that is
related to omega naught, which
h bar omega naught
is equal to 2 delta.
So essentially,
mu E0 is an energy
which is very, very slow
compared to h omega naught.
Now, being very small,
whatever this is,
this time derivative is
going to be very small.
So beta E and beta
g are going to be
very small-time derivatives--
going to move slowly.
If they move slowly over the
time that this oscillates,
this hasn't changed a lot.
And therefore, the average of
this function over that time
is 0, and it doesn't contribute
to the differential equation.
It's actually a good argument.
You can try to
convince yourselves,
or maybe I'll try better
in some way, or something.
But it is right.
I've tried it, actually,
out with computers
and with Mathematica,
and things like that.
And it's really
absolutely true--
that if you think of
differential equations
as integrals, that you
integrate with this
in the right-hand side, you
can see that if this-- really,
the time derivative
is controlled
by this, that corresponds
to a frequency much smaller
than omega naught.
These ones don't matter.
So it's really interesting,
and still not trivial.
But this is a case where we end
up ignoring part of the thing.
So what do we get, then? i beta
E dot is equal mu E0 over h bar
beta g.
And the second equation-- i beta
g dot equal mu E0 over h bar
beta E. Therefore, if
you multiply by another i
here, and differentiate
i-- i beta double dot of E
is equal mu E0 over h bar.
The i extra that we
borrowed, the dot here.
You can use the second equation.
So you get mu E0 over h-bar
squared beta E. Therefore,
beta E double dot is equal to
minus mu E0 over h-bar beta E.
And you, see your
you're rotating
with the a of-- put the
h-bar-- with a frequency
that i much smaller
than omega 0.
So this as a frequency,
this is like omega 0.
So indeed, the rate of
change of this thing
goes with the frequency
that's much smaller.
And it's all right, actually.
So, we've had that, and then
we can write the solution,
finally.
So, what is it?
Beta E of T is cosine
mu E0 t over h-bar.
And the probability
to be in the E state
is the square of that
amplitude, so the probability
to be in the E state at time
t is the square of that.
So it's cos squared
mu E 0 t over h-bar.
Again, I'm sorry,
this beta is here,
and the probability to
be in the excited state
is this square of ce,
but the square of ce
is the square of beta E,
so I just square this.
So there you go.
We have this thing, and we
now have an understanding
of how this goes
as time goes by.
In fact, this mu e 0 T or
h-bar under bar goes by.
This starts to as
a cosine squared,
and then it goes like this.
And this is the place when
this is equal to pi over 2.
So, what do we need?
We need the place
where this happens--
we can call that time T-- be
such that mu E 0 T over h-bar
be equal to pi over
2, or 3 pi over 2.
For those values of time,
the probability to be excited
is zero, and therefore you
must be in the ground state.
These two probabilities
squared added go to 1.
So you're either E or G. So if
you have zero probability to be
in E, you will be
in the state G.
So, the whole issue is
basically at this moment
that you must give
the right speed,
or for a given the
speed of the molecules,
there will be a time that
it takes to traverse.
That time is related
to the steady state
value of this electric
field by this relation.
So you need the right
velocity-- the molecules have
to be at the right
temperature, that's
when they'll have a velocity--
so that they travel in such
a way that is
consistent with this.
As they do that, each of these
particles that goes from E to G
gives out one
photon, one quantum
of the electromagnetic
field, and helps
build the time
dependent electric field
that we started
at the beginning.
Now if you, at some point for
some speed of the molecules,
you saturate this and you
build some electric field,
and then you have your cavity
operating at the nominal way.
And then, of course, you want
to use this for something,
so you shine, let it go out,
and shine those microwaves
or do something.
And if you want to
recharge it, you
keep adding nitrogen molecules.
Now, this was a great
discovery, actually.
Charles Townes,
Gordon, and Zeiger,
built this ammonia
maser in 1953.
They got the Nobel Prize.
Nobel Prize, Charles
Townes got it in 1964.
And he emphasized
that this masers
do the most perfect
amplification
consistent with the
uncertainty principle.
This is a coherent state of
flight that is built here,
and it's much better than any
vacuum amplifier or anything
like that, because the
thing that this giving out
those photons is a molecule
that this uncharged.
So it doesn't disturb
the electromagnetic field
in the cavity as
it goes through.
Many times you use an
electron, for example,
to give out some energy.
But the electron
itself is charged,
so it produces additional
electromagnetic fields,
shot noise, all kinds of noise.
This is absolutely
quiet device in which
is this turns from one state
to another smoothly, stimulated
by the electric field, because
if there was no electric field
would be an energy eigenstate
and then it gives out photon
after photon.
So the uncertainties actually,
in this noble lecture,
which is fun to
read-- in fact, you
remember delta N
delta phi supposed
to be greater than 1/2.
Well, for coherent states as
we more or less discussed,
this thing is saturated.
And what do you have now?
You have a coherent
state of light.
You may remember
that the expectation
value of N in a coherent
state alpha was alpha squared.
And you call this the
number n of photons.
And the uncertainty in
N was, in fact, alpha.
So, it's square root of n.
So for this thing,
we have the situation
in which we are working
with a coherent state that
saturates this.
So delta n times delta
phi is about one half.
And delta n is square root
of the number of photons.
So delta phi is about
to 1 over 2 square root
of the number of photons.
And you can imagine
the cavity easily
can have 10 to the 12
photons, and to 15 photons.
Something fairly big.
And you get an
uncertainty phase.
The thing is coherent.
All the pieces of that
electromagnetic wave,
the phases are very coherent
up to an incredibly great
accuracy.
So it's a great discovery and
the beginning of many things
that were done here, in fact,
by Professor Kleppner and others
in the '60s with
other type of lasers
and masers and this whole thing.
So, that's pretty
much what's I wanted
to say about the ammonia
and these things,
and we're going
to use the last 15
minutes to begin
something else, NMR.
And, so are there any
questions so this Point?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
If it started changing
between states,
I sort of imagine a photon
being omitted and absorbed,
what exactly is happening
then? [INAUDIBLE]?
I just happened to catch
it in the right moment.
PROFESSOR: Well, in this
case, it's basically
omitted all the time, because
we've tuned the cavity in such
a way that if it comes
as E, goes out as G.
So the whole process by
the time that it entered
and it went out, it has to
have omitted one photon.
AUDIENCE: In the
midst of the process,
how does it get back
somehow, because it's
sort of oscillating
between states.
PROFESSOR: It
doesn't get it back.
If the cavity would be
badly designed in such a way
that it may be twice as long,
it would out still come as E.
So it would make
the one transition
and then absorb
another thing, it
would just not
generate anything.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Interesting.
PROFESSOR: And you know,
a more complete discussion
of this, of course, if you
really want to do everything,
you would have to treat
the photon states.
Here, we treated this
as a wave coupled
to the quantum system
of the molecule.
You could treat the photons
themselves as quanta
and do quantum mechanics of
the photon field on that.
And that would be a wave that
you could calculate things more
completely .
But this is not what we do now.
Any other questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So physically, are
the nitrogen molecules all
fixed in the same orientation
going in to this device?
How does that happen?
PROFESSOR: Are the what?
AUDIENCE: The molecules all
fixed in the same orientation?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Essentially it's not
quite like an orientation.
It's an energy eigenstate.
So basically what
you have to do is
have this beam of
ammonia molecules
and do this beam splitter
that we talked about
with the electric field.
And you split the beam into
some that are all excited,
and some that are ground.
And that's it.
You need that everything that
enters here is excited state.
OK.
So another time
dependent problem
that we're going to discuss
today and continue next time
is the NMR problem,
nuclear magnetic resonance.
So this is a pretty
interesting problem.
Our nuclear magnetic resonance.
And it all begins by having
a magnetic field that
has a big component
here, B0, I think.
It's a good name for it.
B0 Z, indeed.
And then you're going to
have some magnetic field that
is going to be rotating here
in time, in the xy plane.
We'll assume that time
equals 0, is here,
and then it's rotating with
some angular frequency omega.
So the total magnetic
field is B0 Z hat
plus some number, B 1--
I'll write it here--
plus B 1 cosine omega t times
x hat minus sine omega t times
y hat.
So, indeed, in the xy
plane, seen like this,
you have it here and it's
rotating with angular frequency
omega this way, clockwise.
All right.
So we have this magnetic field.
And of course we're going
to try to figure out
what spins do in it.
And the magnetic field
is time dependent.
So we're in risk of getting
a time dependent Hamiltonian.
So what is the Hamiltonian?
This possibly time
dependent, it's
supposed to be minus
gamma B times the spin.
So what is that?
It's minus gamma B0 Sz--
The z component matches
with the z component of the
spin-- plus B1, Sx cosine omega
t minus Sy sine omega t.
And, well, it's as bad as you
could imagine, pretty much.
This Hamiltonian
is time dependent.
And there's some good news if
even if it's time dependent,
they commute at different times.
The time evolution is EC.
But no, they don't commute
at different times.
Time equal 0, for example,
you have Sz and Sx,
but at a later time,
you will have Sz and Sy,
and they just don't commute.
So we have no cookbook
recipe to solve this problem.
We have to figure it out.
And there are several
ways to figure it out.
I had a way to figure
it out that I explained
in previous years, but
today I suddenly thought
I could explain it in a
different way that is maybe
a little harder
conceptually, but explains
more of what's going on.
So this is what I
want to try to do now.
And basically what
we're going to try to do
is get the main intuition
going for this problem.
I have the Schrodinger
equation for this problem that
is very complicated with a
time dependent Hamiltonian.
So if you have a wave
function-- and now
I'm going to be a little
rough for a little while.
A h-bar D T H psi.
And it-- oops.
What is it?
Let's see which lights--
Lights, general.
OK.
So if you have a problem
like this, you might say,
well, I would like to do
something non-trivial to this,
so I want to maybe
change the Hamiltonian
and do the same
physical problem.
Now that's not easy, because if
it's the same physical problem,
how can you change the
Hamiltonian all that much?
So one thing you
could do is you can
try to change the states by
doing a unitary transformation,
and then hope that the
unitary transformation acts
on this Hamiltonian.
So this will be the new states.
And you would hope that
this unitary transformation
would somehow, working
with these new states,
would simplify the Hamiltonian.
But unitary
transformations in general
is just like a change of bases.
It's not going to
do all that much,
unless the unitary
transformation has
time dependence, in which
case it doesn't just
rotate the Hamiltonian
but messes up this term.
But this is really your only
possibility of fixing things,
is to try to do a time
independent unitary
transformation that somehow
you started with a spin
Hamiltonian, and you're going
to do a unitary transformation,
and perhaps it's going to
be a time independent one.
But this U is going
to depend on time.
And this is not the
whole Hamiltonian,
because there's a
problem with this part.
So the idea is sort
of vague, but you're
getting a little of the
gist of what we try to do.
So the first thing I tried to
do is something maybe intuitive
about though this system.
I could say that suppose
I have a system here,
and the Hamiltonian is 0.
Nothing.
Nothing happens in that system.
Now the thing that this
curious about this,
that this magnetic
field is rotating.
So let's try to imagine
how would physics
look if you have the xy axis,
and you have the xy axis
rotating with angular
velocity omega.
So the xy in the plane is
rotating with angular velocity
omega.
What would happen?
So there's an Hs
that is originally 0.
You say it's 0, and any
spin state stays there.
There's no time evolution.
H is equal to 0.
Nevertheless, if you jump
into this rotating frame,
all the spin states that
were static, for you
they're rotating.
And in fact, for you, they are
processing around the z-axis
if you're in the rotating frame.
Therefore, in the
rotating frame,
you must have some Hamiltonian,
even though there's
no Hamiltonian in
the static frame.
Because in the rotating frame,
you feel things spinning.
So in the rotating
frame, if there's
a static spin along
the x direction,
you now see it spinning around
the z-axis with frequency
omega, in fact, going
the plus z direction.
So in the rotating
frame you can ask,
what is the new Hamiltonian
in the rotating frame?
I mean, the rotating
frame, the Hamiltonian
should be such that it rotates
the spins with angular velocity
omega around the z-axis.
You may recall that this is
done by all the unitary operator
E to the minus i omega
t Sz hat over h-bar.
This is the operator
that rotates, spins,
with omega t around
the z direction, which
is precisely what you want
this Hamiltonian to do.
So the Hamiltonian must
be e to the minus i ht.
So this rotating Hamiltonian
must be omega Sz hat.
So the Hamiltonian
in the new frame
is that because that Hamiltonian
produces the rotation of states
that you see because your
friend that is not rotating
is telling you that
no state is moving.
H is 0.
So the intuition is
that you've passed
from the original
[INAUDIBLE] to this one,
and you have to add 6 this.
But what we'll see
now is that you
have to add the
little-- you have
to do other things a little
if this is not equal to 0.
Here is what we want to do.
Now there's also a couple
of ways of doing this,
but let me try a
little calculation
to do this second part.
So, we're going to take,
therefore, to have,
for example of psi R a
rotating wave function
that is going to be given
by a unitary operator
times the physical wave
function you want to solve.
This is what you
want, and this is
what you hope has a
simpler dynamics, psi R.
So, let's try to figure
out what is the Schrodinger
equation for psi R if
you know the Schrodinger
equation for psi.
So, I dt I h-bar dt
psi is equal to Hs psi,
let's see what is the
Schrodinger equation satisfied
by this one.
So I h-bar dt of psi R
is I h-bar dt of U psi.
So let's differentiate this.
This is I h-bar dt of U,
and I will have the psi.
But then I will put them a U
dagger, there and another U
acting on psi so that
it gives me psi R.
So the first derivative is
acting just on the U. I acted,
and then I put U dagger U
and recreated the psi R.
The other terms is
in which it acts
on psi, so I get plus I h-bar.
The U goes away,
and now we get dt
of psi, which is I h-bar
dt of psi is Hs I psi,
so I must delete this.
So the second term,
when I acted here,
I act with the whole thing.
I ddt, I h-bar ddt on psi.
The U is out, and I put Hs psi.
And here, I can, of
course, put a U dagger U
and put back the psi R,
so I will do that as well.
U dagger psi R.
So actually you have now a
the Schrodinger equation which
is of the form I
h-bar dt of psi R
is equal to U Hs U
dagger plus I h-bar
dt of U U dagger of
psi R. Now that's it.
This is the new Hamiltonian.
This is the rotating
Hamiltonian, essentially,
that we're trying to figure out
that is going to be simpler,
we hope.
And there we go here.
We have this similarity
transformation
of the Hamiltonian and
we have this extra term.
Now suppose the original
Hamiltonian had been 0.
We want the new Hamiltonian,
given our argument,
to be a this for the
rotating systems.
So I will say that
this U is such
that you get I h-bar dt U
U dagger being precisely
omega Sz.
And for that the U is nothing
else but e to the minus I omega
tSz over h-bar, which is in fact
that thing that we had there.
So that's what U is.
And in that way, this whole
term becomes just omega Sz hat.
So we're almost, in a
sense, done with this thing,
because we have made
some good progress.
Except that we still don't know
if everything has worked out
or not.
I'll continue here.
And just one minute to
close up the discussion
by saying what has happened.
So, what has happened is that
we have found that there's
a new Hamiltonian, HR equal U
Hs U plus I h-bar dtU U dagger.
And then U is given by e
to the minus I omega tSz
hat over h-bar.
And psi-- as we
said, psi of t is
equal to e to the I omega tSz
hat over h-bar psi R of t.
So this came because we
said that psi R was going
to be U psi, and therefore
I took U and the inverse
and you get this.
So look what the
problem has turned into.
It has turned into
a problem for psi R
with a Schrodinger equation
that has a Hamilton HR in which
in this piece is very simple.
It's omega Sz hat.
And now the crucial
point is whether-- here I
have U dagger-- whether this
thing is time independent.
And this should be
time independent
if we got our physics right,
and that's exactly where we'll
take on the next time, and
prove that it's time independent
and then we can solve
the complete problem.
All right, there will be
notes posted on this soon.
Good luck finishing
your homework,
and I think Monday is a holiday.
Is that right?
Well, no class Monday.
We'll see you on Wednesday.